[Musica]
salve youtubers benvenuti ad una nuova
recensione prima di iniziarla come al
solito vorrei consigliarvi un canale il
canale di dave bliskem che per qualche
assurdo motivo mi sono dimenticato di
pubblicizzare prima quindi perdonami
dave e voi andate a guardarvi i suoi
video perché meritano veramente
iscrivetevi e ditegli che vi ho mandato
io detto questo iniziamo ed è di nuovo
sober di sogus
somma
ho scoperto grazie a voi e grazie a
qualche ricerca che ci sono un sacco di
remake turchi quindi aspettatevi molte
recensioni di questi film ovviamente
alternate a recensioni di film più o
meno normali il remake turco di oggi e
star wars il titolo originale e lo devo
leggere perché altrimenti non me lo
ricordo d'una in kurt aran adam
che tradotto significa non siamo capaci
di scrivere una sceneggiatura originale
così rubiamo dagli americani
no in realtà vuol dire l'uomo che salva
il mondo
prima di iniziare subito con i numeri
volevo farvi vedere i titoli di testa di
questo film avete presente i titoli di
testa di star wars la classica scritta
che viaggia nello spazio con la colonna
sonora di sottofondo ecco diciamo che i
turchi ci sono andati abbastanza vicini
[Musica]
wow occhio con gli effetti speciali che
rimango senza fiato e potete smettere di
chiederlo sì questo film esilarante
numero 5 i personaggi
prima però un po di trama astronavi
casinò esplosioni laser un'astronave
cade in un pianeta
due soldati sopravvivono in questo
pianeta c'è un dittatore malvagio i due
sopravvissuti uccidono di stato re
malvagio non assomiglia molto alla trama
di star wars vero e allora perché viene
chiamato star wars turco
lo vedremo più avanti in questo casino
il mondo possiamo vedere i due
protagonisti niente da dire su di loro
tranne che uno non so chi dei due
ovviamente è il regista poi abbiamo il
dart fener della situazione è più che
dart fener sembra uno che deve andare il
carnevale di rio e poi abbiamo
ovviamente l'assistente robotico del
cattivo che quello non manca mai nel suo
baby food classica domanda secondo voi
come può essere fatto questo assistente
robotico
e ve lo devo anche dire che
è un
assomiglia
non ne ho idea
un frigorifero con le braccia ed uccisi
in fondo gli scagnozzi dell'art fener
che se non sbaglio sono direttamente
usciti da un episodio di muppets
questi così dovrebbero includere timore
e lucchetti e molto ma molto più
terrificante di loro
numero 4 i combattimenti il rambo turco
ci ha insegnato che
i turchi non sanno le arti marziali
e lo star wars turco ne è una prova
[Musica]
tra jean di combattimenti con i nemici
che hanno il costume perché se con una
maglietta addosso non riesce a
combattere figurati con un costume c'è
un combattimento sui tappeti elastici
guardate lui salta ci si vede proprio
che prende la rincorsa e salta su un
trampolino ovviamente non inquadrato non
aggiunge nulla di concreto al
combattimento e non appunto dei tappeti
elastici verso la fine compare anche una
spada laser che poi tanto laser non è
e chiaramente un pezzo di cartone
ritagliato e io che mi lamento dei
combattimenti dei film di steven seagal
numero 3 l'addestramento
ok
hanno combattuto ma per i movimenti si
sono addestrati
pensate ad un addestramento di arti
marziali qualsiasi
adesso che ce l'avete in testa guardate
questo
[Musica]
questo è epico per metà
dell'addestramento non fanno altro che
colpire rocce male per giunta come
potrebbe temprati un addestramento in
cui colpisci rocce per tutto il tempo
l'unico altro tipo di addestramento
volta è quello di colpire delle rocce e
quello di legarsi delle rocce alle
caviglie e correre da quel che vedono
sembrano così pesanti quelle facce ma
comunque non magari mi sbaglio io perché
è stupido è semplicemente stupido
numero due regia e suoni come sapete io
non sto tanto a vedere la regia tecnica
di un film squallido perché per me se tu
riesci a mettere due inquadrature
diverse appiccicate che abbiano un senso
sono contentissimo qui ovviamente non
riescono a fare neanche quello
soprattutto nelle scene di combattimento
e soprattutto alle in tutta la parte
girata nelle grotte
io non ho capisce io stavo male stavo
male ho dovuto chiamare in causa tutta
la mia pazienza per non andare avanti in
quelle scene perchè tanto lo stavo
capendo nulla ma la cosa ancora più
fastidiosa di queste scene e l'audio il
maledetto audio che sono stato costretto
ad abbassare i più volte in quelle scene
[Applauso]
se ne sono molti
su tutto il film kitchen occasioni
per fortuna che ho abbassato l'audio
perché sennò diventavo sordo
questo film è spettacolare
numero uno star wars che questo film
viene definito star wars turco ci sarà
un motivo però ve l'ho raccontata la
trama non sa quasi niente a che vedere
con star wars e allora chiederete voi
perché diavolo viene definito in quel
modo beh guardate queste scene vi
ricordano qualcosa
fellow alla moratti
[Musica]
e di giuro che non sono state rifatte
sono proprio state rubate prese pari
pari dal film di star wars
non sono sicuro di come funzioni la
legge in turchia
ma non è illegale e non c'è dubbio che
queste scene siano proprio state rubate
da star wars tra l'altro per fare la
scena iniziale che non ha praticamente
senso ai fini della trama ma dico io se
bevi rubarlo ma almeno montano come si
deve
ma guardate che casino c'è in scena
ma la ciliegina sulla torta è un'altra
io stavo guardando stavo guardando il
film e dopo un po ho sentito qualcosa di
familiare molto familiare
[Musica]
sono riusciti a mettere in un film le
scene di star wars e la colonna sonora
di indiana jones
ok
ha rivolto a questo arrivati a questo
punto 1 cosa fa o si sganascia dalle
risate e continua a guardare i film o si
ammazza ok basta mi fermo qui
questo film ve lo strano consiglio non
so se questo vi consiglio di vederlo con
degli amici
a meno che non vogliate perderli quegli
amici
in quel caso allora ne approfitto per
ringraziarli di tutti gli scritti di
tutti i commenti di tutti i complimenti
e di tutti quelli che condividono i
video su facebook alla prossima
recensione pamparana
[Musica]